so John let's get this thing going tell
me how this film came to be in the
run-up of movies in your room or however
you say it yeah this one kind of sticks
out so tell me how this one came to be
yeah luckily that there was one subject
I was obsessed by that didn't scare
people kind of and so there was a show
on that came out in Baltimore called the
buddy Dean show we never got American
Bandstand ever and it was a dance show
and it was on television six days a week
sometimes five hours a day so these kids
were stars in Baltimore they had hair
higher the boys pants were tighter you
know it was more extreme and so I
watched it every day but it eventually
went off the air because it wouldn't
integrate and they actually did have
Negro Day where black kids came on with
fat daddy the greatest deejay in
Baltimore where every Thursday right no
it was once a month or every two months
it wasn't that good so we'll get to that
yeah so I thought it would be a good
kind of melodrama in a way and also I
wanted the girl that was the star of his
show to be a big girl because there was
never a girl in the buddy Dean show that
was fat ever ever ever so and it turned
out to be a Trojan horse this movie that
snuck in middle America with all my
ideas and nobody even racist like
hairspray but you know one review of it
that was kind of critical said it's a
black history from from a white man's
viewpoint it is definitely I was Tracey
you know we used to go down to the black
neighborhood and and the cops the black
cops hate it it's just as much as the
white cops and they used to stop us
because it was straight and gay rich and
poor white and black teenagers hanging
together
all the cops hated us both sides and
they used to say this didn't Greenwich
Village you know and and when I knew it
was really when I saw it all come to
Isis we all got arrested at the drive-in
once for underage drinking and in the
courtroom all the white kids parents
came down and got him up and the black
kids did not they couldn't get him out
so you know that kind of thing it was
under wallace was running for president
in in maryland at the
so the first protest marches and
everything we went to in high school
really and it was really scary I mean
then you went and people you know it was
riots and stuff so uh it was all true I
was Tracy in a weird way but you know I
wanted to talk about that because I saw
this film as a kid probably too young
because of people that my family would
watch it'd be like what the hell are you
are watching and watch a hairspray and I
could never figure out why the people
started dancing and then I got it you
know
everybody loved the rhythm and the film
but then I saw it again as an undergrad
and a professor was explaining that
there are different different modes of
radicalism and the film's in your early
work are very radical you know they're
they're aggressive as you said pink
flamingos it's not hairspray and yet the
the Verve the energy is all the same and
I think the issues you're dealing with
in this movie they reach a much wider
audience and the issues of some of those
other films so was that a conscious
choice when you know when we got a PG
rating I've said this before I always
thought I'll never work again really and
and I worked very much with New Line
Cinema and and I think some of them not
Sarah Richard who was the producer that
really helped me on this movie she's
here tonight - yeah and but some of the
people who knew who I wanted me to put
in the word [ __ ] so I'd get a pg-13 I
said no this is what's shocking that
it's a PG it's the and and Devine got
the best reviews of his life because he
was playing against type which was this
monster we made up to scare hippies you
know people think Tim I'm was trans he
didn't want to be a woman he wanted to
be Godzilla you know so so I never at
the time thought it was I had written a
more commercial movie or anything you
know it surprised me completely when and
but then it did work and and and I
certainly embraced that fact you know I
always wanted to be commercial are you
kidding I was surprised all of them
didn't make money I was the only one
that was surprised